carrot cake a delicious way to get some
vegetables in it almost feels kind of
healthy almost it certainly doesn't
taste healthy when it's done right
sometimes carrot cake can be really hit
or miss but let me tell you when it's
done well that cake can be beautifully
baked perfectly moist and melts in your
mouth filled with the perfect mix of
spices slather it with some velvety
decadent cream cheese frosting and it's
to die for we're going to show you how
to make a carrot cake that is moist and
flavorful
[Music]
we're going to start off with our star
ingredients carrots you can control the
size and the moisture content of the
carrots when you hand grate them so when
you're shopping for them you want to
look for the biggest carrots you can
find so they're easier to grate
we'll be using the large side of the
hand grater for added texture in our
cake to really highlight the carrots
store-bought shredded carrots are often
just too thick and they've been dried
out to preserve them so they lack that
flavor and moisture content we're
looking for okay the first thing we need
to do is create a parchment round to
line our cake pans take a small
rectangle of parchment fold it in half
we'll fold it in half again then we'll
bring up the closed tip to create a
narrow triangle
place that closed tip in the center of
the cake pan and then we're going to
mark the edge of the cake pan and cut
off the excess parchment this way when
you unfold that triangle it should be a
perfect circle that fits in the bottom
of your cake pan now that you have your
perfect circle the best way to secure it
to the pan is to use a little bit of
non-stick spray place the parchment
circle inside and press down and then
spray the top of the parchment and the
edges of the cake pan to really make
sure your cake does not stick
now we're gonna preheat our oven to 350
degrees fahrenheit let's make this cake
in a large bowl we're going to combine
the grated carrots and buttermilk and
we're going to stir them until the
carrots are completely coated the fat
and acid from the buttermilk helps
create a tighter and more tender cake
crumb if you use whole milk it lacks
acidity and creates a coarser crumb if
you use sour cream it has extra fat and
creates a much finer crumb and creates a
little bit more of a dense texture
when measuring your flour keep in mind
that there's a difference when you're
scooping versus spooning to level your
flour if you just stick your measuring
cup into your bag of flour the scooping
can pack it too tightly and you'll end
up using just more flour than the recipe
intends
what we like to do is spoon our flour
into the measuring cup and level it to
ensure that we're using a true cup full
we're also going to use whole wheat
flour for a toasty and gram flavor and
it'll also help absorb some of that
carrots moisture let's sift together the
all-purpose flour and whole wheat flours
with the baking powder cinnamon ground
ginger salt baking soda ground cloves
ground allspice and some freshly grated
nutmeg the carrot cake spice is
generally closer to that of a
gingerbread it's definitely more ginger
and cinnamon forward in the bowl of our
stand mixer we're going to combine the
brown sugar granulated sugar eggs and
vanilla extract then we'll fit it with
the whisk attachment and beat it on
medium speed until the mixture begins to
drop from the whisk in disappearing
ribbons it'll take about three minutes
keep in mind the importance of using
room temperature ingredients keeping all
of your ingredients at room temp will
help to create a better emulsification
of the batter also eggs that are at room
temp will trap air more easily which
turns into steam in the oven and creates
a light and fluffy cake texture it's
important to aerate the eggs fully to
create that volume with the mixer
running on medium speed we're going to
slowly drizzle in the vegetable oil make
sure to use a neutral oil like vegetable
oil or grape seed you can even use
sunflower we just don't want to
overpower our cake with flavor so
something like an olive oil is not going
to be great here now the oil does not
want to mix with the water content from
the eggs so you need to incorporate the
fat real slow while whisking real fast
to properly emulsify and create a smooth
thick texture use a rubber spatula to
scrape down the sides of the bowl
halfway through just to make sure
everything is getting incorporated
continue mixing until the mixture is
fully emulsified it's probably going to
take about two minutes now we're going
to alternate adding our dry mixture and
our carrot mixture so we're going to
start by adding a third of the flour
mixture and we'll mix it on low speed
just until the flour starts to get
incorporated
then we'll add a half of the carrot
mixture and continue mixing on low speed
until that feels incorporated we'll
continue alternating adding the flour
and the carrot mixtures
if you add all the dry ingredients at
once it can make the batter too thick
and difficult to mix into which can
cause over mixing in the end
but if we add all the wet ingredients at
once it could cause the emulsification
process to separate and it's difficult
to bring the mixture back together once
it's broken
now we're going to remove the bowl from
the mixer and use a flat rubber spatula
to bring the batter together if we keep
the whisk on and we over mix the cake
batter it'll just make the cake chewy
and dense and we want to finish gently
mixing the batter together so we're
going to use the rubber spatula to make
sure everything is incorporated
we made our carrot cake to highlight the
carrots but people often add fruit and
nuts if we were using all these mixins
we'd coat them in flour so they don't
sink to the bottom of the pan when we're
baking now let's evenly divide the
batter between the prepared cake pans
it's not the sexiest cake batter pour
but wait till it's baked it'll be
totally worth it we're going to bake
them until a toothpick inserted into the
center of the cake comes out clean it'll
take about 25 minutes let the cakes cool
for like 10 minutes and then remove them
from the pans and let them cool
completely
now we're on to carrot cake's bestie
that cream cheese frosting we're going
to take ours to the next level and add
real vanilla bean we'll cream it
together with butter cream cheese
vanilla extract and the salt
then we'll add the powdered sugar and
continue mixing until it's silky and
smooth okay now we're ready to build
this thing so we're going to place a dab
of frosting on the cake board and then
we'll place the cooled cake layer on top
to secure it to the board
we're going to use a cookie scoop to
help us measure the frosting and also
it's just so much cleaner then we'll
spread it evenly across the top and
we'll continue with the other two layers
then we'll top this whole thing with
whatever remaining frosting we have left
over we're not going to be shy about
this
now that batter shot was not cute but
this is so sexy
[Music]
isn't that just so satisfying
[Music]
there you have it a carrot cake recipe
that is moist flavorful and stunning so
when you want to go for that second
slice remember there's carrots in there
and carrots are healthy
you can tell yourself i don't care at
all see what i did there i'm definitely
winking you just can't see it
all right i'm done
[Music]
you